so here's is the point that i'm making
with regards to the left it's all about
the power
it is not about fundamental principle
it's about how they gain and maintain
power
i do not accept the honesty of the
principles they supposedly promulgate
i think they are lying to you i think
they're lying to me
i think that if they believe this stuff
they're lying to themselves i don't
think that they hold any of these
standards
i think that when people are convenient
then they get to outlive
their their bad act and when they are
inconvenient then we just dispose of
them
and just to flex their power every so
often you'll see the left just
get somebody to issue an apology for no
reason at all right so ilhan omar never
issued an apology for anything she's
ever said
but the left will force lin-manuel
miranda to offer his latest apology so
remember lin-manuel miranda
has been forced to sort of offer
apologies for having written hamilton
how dare he not make slavery the key
issue
in the founding of the united states in
hamilton and he had to issue some some
apologies for that well now lin-manuel
miranda
is having to issue apologies for in the
heights which is a racially diverse
musical about people
in crown heights in new york
who are of minority persuasion what did
he do wrong
according to variety.com lin-manuel
miranda is now addressing criticism over
the film's lack of afro-latino
representation
in a statement posted to twitter miranda
apologized for not including more
dark-skinned afro-latinos in the film's
cast especially in the leading roles i
started writing in the heights because i
didn't feel seen and over the past 20
years all i wanted was for us all of us
to feel seen miranda's statement begins
i'm seeing the discussion around after
latino representation in our film this
weekend
it is clear many in our dark-skinned
afro-latino community don't feel
sufficiently represented within it
particularly among the leading roles the
discussion miranda mentioned stems from
a video article in the root
published on wednesday which points out
there are no dark-skinned afro-latinos
in the film's leading roles
so very important for him to apologize
now
miranda ended his statement by saying he
would try to do better in the future try
to do better in the future
meanwhile the left is trying to cuddle
apologies out of tom hanks because tom
hanks is not sufficiently anti-racist
he's just not a racist
so npr ran an op-ed from a person named
eric degens titled tom hanks
is a non-racist it's time for him to be
anti-racist see they're just gonna
cuddle you into the corner
if you are a person who is a lifelong
democrat
but you have not done sufficient work
you have not done the work they will
cuddle you into the corner because again
it is not
about principle it's about power
politics it's about getting people on
board for whatever your radical agenda
is today
this article is is pretty much a master
class in this eric degen's over at npr
he writes
first i must note how much i love tom
hanks as a performer hollywood citizen
an all-around stand-up guy
of course he's a consummate actor with
two oscars and starring roles in
landmark films such as philadelphia and
forrest gump
he's been an outspoken advocate for gay
rights and environmentalism
so when i saw he had recently written a
guest essay for the new york times
calling for more widespread teaching
about the tulsa race massacre
i was sincerely heartened now i thought
we'll see him examine how his work
so often focused on the achievements of
virtuous white
male americans may have made it tougher
for tales about atrocities such as tulsa
to find similar space you see
it turns out saving private ryan was not
about tulsa but it should have been
about tulsa
so tom hanks is a bad white man
but says eric diggins he didn't fully go
there here's what he did say quote
history was mostly written by white
people about white people like me
while the history of black people
including the horrors of tulsa was too
often left out
until relatively recently the
entertainment industry which helps shape
what is history and what is forgotten
did the same
that includes projects of mine then he
goes on to say he learned of tulsa from
an article in the new york times last
year
and another line later in the piece
today i think historically based fiction
entertainment must portray the burden of
racism in our nation for the sake of the
art form's claims to various
varisimilitude and authenticity says
eric tekkens
these are wise words but it is not
enough
he built a career playing righteous
white men
after many years of speaking out about
race and media in america i know the
toughest thing for some white americans
is to admit how they were personally and
specifically connected to the elevation
of white culture above other cultures
but in hanks's case he's no average
american or average hollywood star for
that matter
over the years he has starred in a lot
of big movies about historical events
including saving private ryan
greyhound forrest gump apollo 13 bridge
of spies and news of the world he has
served as producer or executive producer
on even more films and tv shows based on
american history
including band of brothers the pacific
john adams and from the earth to the
moon
in other words he's a baby boomer star
who has built a sizable part of his
career on stories about american white
men
doing the right thing but the stories
often leave
out black contributions they often leave
out how black soldiers returned home
from fighting in world war
ii to find out they weren't allowed to
use the gi bill to secure home loans in
certain neighborhoods or were cheated
out of claiming benefits at all so
let's just be clear this guy is now
angry at tom hanks because saving
private ryan didn't end
with a black member of the platoon going
home and being rejected from the gi bill
which would have fit seamlessly into the
plot of the film
obviously he should have done that no
tom hanks must be cudgelled
it's the difference between being a
non-racist and being an anti-racist
he's saying it's time for folks like
hanks to be quote unquote
anti-racist if he really wants to make a
difference hanks and other stars needs
to talk specifically about how their
work has contributed to these problems
and how they will change it's all about
mao's struggle sessions it's
all about power that's what we're
focused on here at home who can we
culturally
do what the left wants not confronting
foreign adversaries not strengthening
america
how can we cudgel other americans into
doing what we want politically by
upholding standards that are completely
hypocritical and
utterly inconsistent on every level
that's where we are
so good luck to us over the next few
years the battle for the culture is
heating up we here at the daily wear are
making some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment